[Music]
general grievances
alright guys put the phones away please
where's fire team ever episode this is
why we're the work ain't all poured our
try to alright worse fire team ever
episode 7 here we are all right guys
it's taco I mean eight you're correct
[Music]
so hey so real quick let's let's start
with grievances remember it's all loved
but let's just air our grievances what I
mean well problems we have we're talking
about it
I'll start kkd whoring she will shoot
should we all look up Arkady's no we
know that his is gonna be the best dude
he got so mad one night what night was a
recent no we saw you playing with these
other people those trials yeah well I
was great Vincennes let's talk let's
talk about it because this one of my
biggest pet peeves
No one of my biggest pet peeves will
Steve is recently Steve will send me
messages through Xbox we got this whole
group chat right right
Steve's never on the group chat but I'll
hear from Steve he'll send me a message
through Xbox oh I see I see your I see
your play know someone else huh you know
kind of throw in slide light but you're
offline so we know that's my Grievous
with Steve is that you don't even know
when he's on you like we're already in a
party yeah in this [ __ ] I've
sent a party invite invite everybody
yeah just join our party let's hurry I
don't get a party invite from Steve okay
enjoy myself cuz when I was online I
noticed I don't know it's because of
this podcast but random people from that
world okay would be I gotta get message
message you know just random people just
hitting me up like it's all part of the
famous TV whoa I'm on the road in people
you know another grievance I have with
your ass okay I'm on the road doing
stand-up you know and people coming up
to me like hey bro I'm being known for
being on the what happened at the Comedy
Store some you would to see you're in my
house my favorite is you kept yelling at
me for not following you on Instagram
and then I looked on my Instagram I was
like oh yeah I I do follow you one of
the og originals yeah we meet you and
Bob okay and myself
[Laughter]
so you got the door you have the door
and you made a choice to get a dog a
piano and a girl he brings a girl
breathing and it's crazy when he's
trying to play like before he would play
and then you'd be like you just can't
whisper laughs two hours on Sundays
sunday came you could even talk sunday
came and we were looking forward to
playing with you and then you you know
you had to go to the horror ville over
here
part of the reason why it's kind of
change for me is my girl noticed that
when I play specifically PvP like my
energy changes it's not even your fault
this is like I get mad oh and she goes
she doesn't like it when I get okay but
you play but you get mad I don't get mad
because I got when you'd that when
you're playing okay so I don't play
against other people I do I do like
Ultimate Team you know what I mean it's
like you know whatever problem here's
but here's the question here's the
question Steve how how much PvP did we
play destiny one I didn't play till the
end but that's all we did that's that's
all we did and do you do you like it
that you enjoy I love it that's all that
matters and that's where you got to
relate
we have a solution she says you're not a
Nazi
if you can't play in your own apartment
even when you go over there we're gonna
work it out is it because I I think it's
twofold issue either a tight space and
it's like it's distracting and annoying
to her that when you're playing which is
valid that's what it is or or it could
be the thing where it's like hey you're
giving that attention issue to solution
like how do you guys deal with that
[Laughter]
Steve here's the thing we talked about
it right we have a promise Steve you
have a promissory note right okay you're
gonna come over right the only thing we
want from you is a promise that you'll
do it we were disappointed because there
should be repercussions if he doesn't do
it the promise there's you know what be
fun because like we'll be like doing
better PvP cuz I'll actually see his
movements and be like no no you fussing
a Craig because now I own ow I here
Craig over here is mister power ammo now
always talking about no no no no I don't
with in two days
Fortuna this dude's camp for heavy more
than than he ever did for no dude not
more than great let me let me tell you
let me tell you this was the other day I
spawned right next to to Craig right
there's 45 seconds on the heavy ammo 45
seconds to wait not only that he's
sitting there so like let's say the
power n Mo's back here right he's facing
out does he put up a shield shield
shield on Berkey for 45 seconds
we're out here dying on the Craig guy at
the raid rocket which I just got the
raid rocket launcher and so I wanted to
practice with it yeah and also practice
with the rock you get it you
dishonorable [ __ ] I don't know
it's a drop I'm defending here let me
just say my last piece by the way the
reason this guy gets angry is cuz he
goes for it we go for it at the same
time putting up your shield to him no no
no no my favorite move is to use my
fists of hat no you use my shoulder
charge to hit coke out of the way yeah
he's done that well here's here's here's
my deal I'm constantly moving I'm not
gonna sit there in verse 10 seconds I
may wait if my team's all there but 45
[ __ ] I agreed I was 14 he was
hoarding and argument argument we're
gonna give his argument is to practice
with it
it's a [ __ ] rocket launcher all
rocket launchers work the same somebody
you shoot it it was a cluster bomb I had
to get used to Buster bombs don't even
work you know why that rocket launches
yeah you know okay so now okay fair
enough fair enough I was being a dick
but I only did it this week it wasn't
like I've been doing it since the day
one Sam John don't worthy spawn to be
honest I don't even know where the heavy
spawns on the map then they change okay
I got a grievance let's go into this
Katie whoring Oh cuz I started with it
oh you're trying to move it on him now
yeah we sort and brief I'm not this [ __ ]
now new rivalry we all know coke is the
best there's no dispute that coke he's a
lot he reminds us every day not that we
need to disagree yeah well you have to
hear about it again I'm just proud I'm
just like you know if he was like a you
know like a pennant winner for the you
know like baseball he beat every day
guess what I want a pennant floyd
mayweather of our yeah no wfe yeah we're
the worst fire team ever
well he's the best on the worst so so
that being said but so the thing is when
I play I play for fun I'm going to have
fun my friends I wanted sometimes I want
to do well I give us trials or
competitive rounds tonight yes but but
if it's if it's like one of those I want
to put my best foot forward but the rest
of time I'm having fun this guy treats
it like you know if if his Cady drops
point zero-zero get 1% it's like you
[ __ ] like I used to be in a
2.79 12 you know I know if you don't try
it's like sometimes I feel like which
moves us to Frank I I had to have the
talk with Frank about taking it a little
more serious you know cuz we have this
podcast we're trying to do and Frank's
on there [ __ ] take it hits of a bong
during the gameplay order and Thai food
with his girlfriend you know just out of
nowhere we're gonna hear a vacuum
cleaner that was destiny one
we're here hahaha my mom we gotta hear
Snoop Dogg [ __ ] but it's a French credit
he said okay cuz coat I'm gonna speak
because you don't want to get on you
right now because he's very competitive
we're doing trials yeah yeah your asses
standing there and all we hear all we
hear in the background is like okay okay
so let me let me hear let me hear this
which one a win trials fair enough fair
enough let me let me let me defend
myself a little bit okay so this this is
my my thought process so like when I'm
when we're playing casually to have fun
I don't harp that much when we're doing
like quick play but that's why I'd like
to do a quick play cuz quick play even
if I die even if I'm getting [ __ ] up
right because everybody's not playing
good and I'm getting [ __ ] up I don't I
don't complain at least I get to revive
and keep shooting right don't [ __ ] I
hate playing like countdown and playing
with people that are dying and then I
just die and then or I die if I die
first
and then I gotta sit there and wait and
then what run make mistakes well it's
not even that I just want to be going
like if you guys watch me play I'm
constantly [ __ ] moving so I hate I
hate waiting the whole time and then I
hate doing the trials card where you
know well we got to reset the card and
we played the same map over and over and
over
so like I'm competitive when it comes to
trials because I won't get that [ __ ]
done I want to go through and I want I
want everybody to be honed in and taking
it serious so we can get the [ __ ] done
because if you don't take it seriously
in trials you're not gonna get no so
that's what we're doing it more you know
but I agree with trials I'm talking
about the rest of the like I mean
literally we could be playing like the
lamest game-mode it'll be supremacy
which I hate
and gonna be like why aren't you I'm
positive my Katy is positive I don't
care Felix I'm tired of hexagon caching
and [ __ ] [ __ ] because he's
talking about supremacy I'll tell you
what it's about supremacy because it all
started when supremacy why don't you
know he's not he's not no no no listen
I'm about to I'm about to break this
[ __ ] down supremacy this this is where
it started because I think I had like a
KD like 7.0 got all these kills [ __ ]
fine but it was supremacy it was
supremacy right yeah so Craig made a
little comment about Oh coke didn't pick
up any kress so this is this is what
driving me [ __ ] nuts but that is
annoying because that's the game man
listen that's what you know you guys are
fixated on you got to pick up the crest
that's true but what creates kress kills
kills if I'm sitting over here with 22
kills Craig's got three [ __ ] kills
and he's got all the Naboo who killed
all the people for him to pick up the
crest is it harder to kill a person or
go run pick up a crest it's harder to
kill people you need to get kills in
order not only that okay he says KD
doesn't yep he says KD he says KD
doesn't matter in supremacy the thing is
when you die what do you drop you drop
across you give the crest so two things
okay never on two coke I've been playing
control supposed to control like I hate
to see your thing says zero okay but I
get I don't care I won't go and I'll
defend code on that cuz it's like earn
cuz you'll run bastard what else always
we got some I go run in a
if someone else if I see two guys
already if something 1.00 yeah I'm poor
I'm point eighty he's uh point six zero
point two five because I just don't care
your point what cokes in there I want to
do that point but but the control they
they all have they all have their hold
on line they all have their their
aspects yeah you got to get you got to
get zones but the thing is you don't get
points with the zones if you don't get
killed
yeah if you get a negative Kady you're
losing your team points and you're
giving them points Kady has a big part
to deal with every game how about will
be just when we spawn the first one I
would hate when he would run right past
yeah I get that because I know people
get the first one but if we're both
rushing B then that pushes them off what
I like to do is I like to swing all the
way around and get a our famous four
famous big fight Evers Steven Steven
Frank I got so mad at you during control
member because was I wasn't killing
anybody no no because you weren't
getting you the zone yeah yeah and then
the next time oh my god Steve it was my
now it's gone down a little Steven
here's the thing Steve better but also
you can remember it also factors as much
of you play so if you play more and you
play more competitive than you know it
goes up and down
I beat Griffin by 0.6 Craigs but I mean
also that's a game play so it goes Eric
Steve me Griffin Craig no no it's right
Griffin Griffin oh yeah me and Griffin
play a lot I think a lot more than Frank
so of course our KD is balanced by how
much we play and how much we win or lose
I play a lot
okay so that under Steve so me and Craig
and I haven't got anything to verify
this but we're like we know Steve's on
and he's not playing with us and we
don't know if because Steve has this
weird thing where he wants to play the
story himself and he he wants to level
up because he doesn't want to be the
lowest level yeah yeah he fails you'll
join you and there you can't even Steve
[Music]
disappears but we try to tell Steve like
you're gonna get higher quicker if
you're playing with the group playing by
yourself you're gonna love the last
episode yeah no but the clan episodes
are kind of nice cause like you don't
have to necessarily like we finished the
raid the clan got rewards do we match
that for the season weakly there's
weekly tasks there's nine for the season
yeah we maxed it we have a pretty big
clan though there's a lot of people and
friends I don't know half them but
that's why I do notice that but listen
listen that's why I didn't want our clan
to be worse fire team ever because we
get rewards based off what everybody
does and if we had just us in a clan we
wouldn't level our clan up yeah all the
way you know what I'm saying though I
mean in a sense I still want to get
reverse clan like most of those people I
don't even we're getting credit for it
so like cuz I only play with you guys
and then meskhi how'd you find these
guys who are they I made I made meskhi
and dev admins so they they just so
anybody I mean that's partly the reason
to to be honest because I don't have
these guys oh my god we don't play with
them we don't play with them in the clan
yeah there while they're doing [ __ ]
we're getting experience for it we don't
I sighs I spy okay now look and I'll
know thing comes out
and I'm spying on though you don't like
to be like party with randoms yeah got
to and but I already know you guys
already have a set team like four dudes
well I'm one line quick play it on my
god he'll jump out we jump out to play
with our team yeah our people if we know
it like here's the thing if you were
online and we saw your online if we're
playing with two randoms as soon as that
game's over boom well this goes back to
we should just do a Kickstarter for a
monthly Kickstarter let's get a patreon
no but I have the space and we can do
the sugar mama out there but I'll hook
it up in my place I will say there there
are people in the clan though that like
that we do play with quite a bit like
meskhi gab someone that I want to cross
clamming and and a newer guy ghost ghost
Lupo because he actually him and his
guys got dike Pikachu I need two hours a
Sunday a good shooter so when you get
fun to do we got a war when you get that
when you get thank you doing I only do
the first part having when you get that
when you get that raid Ingram from
Hawthorne or whatever it's only like
level 10 you got to upgrade it when you
do those when you do the raid though you
get high you get higher drops alright so
you get that high I mean it goes up
you're my bro yeah yeah and honestly the
raids not it's not hard way if you do
well that know what they're doing I've
done a few of the things we got through
it in two hours fun like we did but yeah
it's a lot of like it's a lot of like
puzzles and talking and like that one
thing we do the guys are running around
to start the dahle I gotta tell you
which ones to shoot yeah so our last
episode 6 was our raid footage from the
first attempt we did which sadly Frank
wasn't there but the rest
it was painful because I realized Mount
Airy does it that's the thing I like
about Craig passive-aggressive [ __ ]
no we did the radio Frank wasn't there
of course we were half the time Frank's
out doing a show and where were you
yesterday I'm Marco Hayley I was in
similar pranks all over the place but I
was just going back to it was so painful
for years you were leaving I was leading
you yeah and it was it was hard because
I realize like I was reading a website
that was giving me terrible directions
on how to do that raid my magic terrible
directions push me yeah plus year and
that is the word I'm out no so like I
was terrible the raid was there but it's
like that was a thing as like so when
you play with these guys and they know
what they're doing yeah it changed up so
when I look back that was also the thing
that people don't know is well that they
won't know is like we just started that
that rate had just come out yeah we
wanted to play it what's it called
Leviathan goodbye and we were on like
the dolphin which the dogs is a hard map
because how do you do that thing well
you have to know the sections these guys
call it r1 r3 oh well they got code and
they know where that's the thing that
when you okay one thing I notice so
Steve when you play with people there is
a there is a moment of like would you
have to take time to hear how they do it
you know because because they have
everybody like on the gauntlets yeah
I've seen two different people two
different ways they do it like some
people call like they call out there
like number like top bottom or somebody
else calls out like just a one of you
[ __ ]
yeah yeah that's what we did that works
but yeah it's like everybody it's a lot
of like just like listening and like
okay what do you want what do you want
us to do it's just Craig's horrible it
but what what what I do like though
absolutely when we did it with ghosts
they did a good job of explaining even
like they did do that what happens
during that that mission or like that
yeah well like whoa we were talking
about the Goblin because I was I was
worried about it because they're like
they're like okay Craig Pete sue you
guys don't really know were runners
they're like no they may be in the
runners I thought the runners were like
because I've never done it so I thought
that was the hardest part I'm like is
that a good idea and then I found out it
was literally just running and calling
out whatever we did it it's not my
question is we didn't clear those
planets the best oh hi Vaughn the moon
yeah you know like what are we just
there now we've just left like all the
Guardians are like good luck moon yeah
that stuff's still happening there I
want to I want to be able to do those
real okay they'll bring it back I'm sure
they will they're bringing back guns
next season they better step it up man
they're going back to listo because they
already get rid of all these they're
getting they're bringing like the moon
is still there that's the thing like
they're gonna build up just open it up
will but it's just you know yeah but
they will I mean that's what they did
with you know the first one I took a
long time and they built it up now I
think we're getting close toward the end
we got about 15 minutes ish so I wanted
to talk about basically I thought let's
talk about what got the last great game
like or the first great game that got
you like really into gaming like I just
like you start what you start all right
well for me like I got I mean I you know
I belong yeah donkey gone
no like I gotta say like the I got out
of gaming and then in college my buddy
introduced me back into Goldeneye
that goldeneye that sucked me I mean
every because I would only play it on
super hard yeah but it was a great game
and that was like one of the first first
person I think that was sponsored by
Isis person my sister Carol ruined me
and my cousins like we would get into
fistfights that'd ruin relationships
because that was how all of our cousin's
got killed established the hierarchy
like who was the coolest was who could
wreck at [ __ ] Goldeneye Goldeneye was
great man it just it was a it was really
brought that was like a fun thing but it
wasn't online yet to play four people in
a room for me it was Gears of War
here's the wars that won't gain that I
the first time I started like actually
it wasn't the time people Gears of War
with someone and then they ruined it
with Gears of War two because they
opened up like how many slots for is
perfect yeah or before for like when you
have a group of four you could talk over
each other you can hear everything once
it went to like five six it's out is
over it's like you know when you're
going like one of arrows groups we love
you era but God you know but like four
was a thing so that was the first time I
was like that I realized it it brought a
level of enjoyment to the game that like
without it like I wouldn't play destiny
if there wasn't talking to people and
playing like we do know especially
destiny more like the story was all
fractured and you don't know what the
[ __ ] was going on
no the core of it is like being able to
play with people so that's the first
time I was like oh this is actually fun
then I started playing like you know
sports I like playing sports games
online but but mostly that Gears of War
was the one that got me in there like
into halo for me halo was the big big
one I remember was again my aunt's house
I went to like Blockbuster and I was
like oh this is cool because when the
Xbox first came out and I rented it and
I remember playing it
I made my cousin who's a it was a girl I
made her play as the second character
and we played through that whole [ __ ]
story line just in that one night and it
was just I just playing it and just
being addicted to it because there's
such a good story the pistol with the
sniper scope on it the worst the first
pistol yeah the three headshot kill you
from like a mile dude the most broken
gun halo2 came out and I was working on
a TV shows years ago and I don't even
want to name the show because it dates
me but hazard hazard number but they the
grips had put three X boxes in the
trailer and we were into their truck and
we would go in their lunch and just halo
2 we would have like all the people at
forum those were the fun days when you
ho land part let's light the bit connect
your Xboxes oh yeah first person
shooters oh wait so anyway so yours was
halo ok Steve go ahead woman Shadow the
Colossus that's one of mine was ICO
which was the game before that by the
same Sony Bremen and that was just
amazing and then [ __ ] all the
fallouts follow the phones were
bioshock's first game all the grand
theft [ __ ] oh yeah yeah the Bioware is
real fun Bioshock was don't were to pare
it down to 100 Sasson screeds first one
well there's so many red dead redemption
i [ __ ] love that but pare it down to
one like what's the one game that like
really like sucked you into gaming
that's like you know Skyrim [ __ ] me up
yeah dude I bought the remastered
edition I had to return it I was like I
you're like mining magic you were like
mining and [ __ ] iron bobbies are born
at Oh Bobby was like whoa Jordan's got
well joining about Jordan got Bob into
it yeah the more Owen yeah just imagine
that Jordan got Bobby do you remember
the first time the dragon comes down
just like what does
[ __ ] yeah that's great what was yours so
the first game I mean I was super young
but it was on a Super Nintendo a little
bad well my first game that got me in
the game oh yeah every fight or two
we're gonna go back in the 80s arcade
[ __ ] well I remember Gordon our you'd
have to go the arcade to put the corner
in [ __ ] that was Street Fighter II yes
Dragon's Lair oh yeah that must eh yeah
I was where I was way too young Street
tempest I can't just go on no but I
think the game Steve how old Gallagher
kidding there was that was the fun that
was the heydays was going to the arcades
I gotta know when you see it in movies I
kind of missed those like stranger
things yeah murder they arcade like the
arcade the place you would go talk to
arcades like blockbuster now on yes well
we have a better arcade Justin where you
live now they have arcade arcade arcade
bar so yeah I we have a couple of
Milwaukee and they're pretty it's
competitive
well they got they have you ever played
the pac-man tables my stepdad
that was my stepdad side business my
stepdad had a bunch of arcade games and
he'd switch I'm at a different
restaurants but well girl in high school
we just had arcade yeah we had arcade
games just in my garage and my friends
would just come over and be like what
you guys got [ __ ] arcade games or
would you play there was a Crotty game
do you remember I had two joysticks yes
yes it was the karate champ Crotty champ
remember track and field yeah yeah yeah
we track a field people used to put like
a pencil you guys don't remember this
because you have to like
I remember the first Nintendo because I
remember contra and manicurist Tecmo
Bowl oh you had Tecmo Bowl well I just
going back to one favorite time I go was
the first game on ps2 that I play I want
to tell you because you like you know
shadow shadow well I co was the first
game they did and when I played it I was
like oh man this is gonna be amazing
this generation of gaming like this is
gonna be and I thought like all games
are gonna feel like this because it's a
beautiful game it's a look there's no
talking it's all just kind of like
character driven but it's done through
emotion like emotes and and then when it
ended like I was like I was so excited
for games like that but it was really
that one developer it was that one guy
who that one main guy I think his name
is you ADA he did like I go shadow and
Trico or wood glass guardian those games
are amazing they're beautiful there are
like what got me like cuz I went from
playing all types of games even back
like when I was younger I'd play like
Baldur's Gate like because I play it
once PlayStation came out and I played
Final Fantasy 7 I I was into RPGs yeah
that's all I did
yeah so like on computer and stuff like
that but then like lady said when xbox
dropped and my dad got it for me opening
day and got me halo after halo versus
juniors that was what was he'll early
2000 it was the first yeah it was for
the first it was the platform game for
the X Y a it was like the first time I
really what Bungie sure I don't know I
got I heard it through you guys because
it was maybe they did a good ad campaign
I thought they really did a good push
and I was like just came out I remember
getting into it and talking to you about
it like when I first started working at
the store and I was just like hey I'm
getting into this and it was like yeah I
was trying to talk to you about like
motes of light and you're like you know
you need to learn more noise like what
what you like you know what most lights
are and yeah I play with you level 20
see I was most few here that was just
you trying too hard
these guys talk about I never asked over
but that's what you were saying see I
get my get my super competitive nature
cuz I was a Call of Duty guy so I was
all I played was called duty for years
and shout out to meskhi our boy mash key
because he's known him that long I've no
dude I've known for a while call duty
ghost you guys I couldn't do people in
there and it would always get racial
yeah but but uh we we we played that I
didn't even know destiny was a game I
didn't know it was like this big
up-and-coming like Bungie release I had
no ideas the day of mess key told me we
were playing Call of Duty sign Oh
destiny destiny comes out today I gotta
go get that and I was gonna check my
head yeah I was like I need a new game I
went out and got that [ __ ] as soon as I
got two hours and I was like I'm not
playing call duty again like this is my
[ __ ] because I love that that one Jesus
to smoothest game Bungie so really good
but their game see for me it's like when
I hear how much money they spent on
making the game that I'm in because when
grand theft auto 5 came out and it was
roll that striking out the game and all
the news about it and the guy like he
invested all this money whatever was
going on I heard how much money they
spent and when I played that game I was
like I was blown away this is so amazing
with Michael the one with her destiny
spent equivalent money same amount of
money like that they spent you know five
hundred million dollars I was like well
this is gonna be a great game mm-hmm I
gotta check it out that's the reason why
I checked it I know what I liked about
GTA is like you do rent you can make you
create your own game like I would just
take my sniper rifle and then what see
what cars would come and I would snipe
him through the window dude a their head
would hit the No
than the choppers no no I had two games
I'll play to two things I was on my own
type of game I would get a tank oh yeah
and then I would just like just kill
people kill people so the cops would
come you get a rather you just army well
my second one was like I would try to
get I would go to the airport this is
where I always do I go to the airport
the plane an army base so I do that
okay wait by the way my favorite my
favorite open-world game is infamous
like that I gotta tell you I gotta tell
you my Grand Theft Auto thing that I do
what I would like to do is I would I get
a bus I go to the comedy store I sign up
oh wait I'll get a bus and I'll take it
to the freeway and I'll cut off a whole
leg oh then I'll let all of the cars
build up and I'll just plant c4 and then
I'll blow it all up immediately I don't
if you played it recently I still play
it every now and then they got this like
energy gun that you could like you know
I love that well I gotta say grand theft
was amazing for the high baby because
when it was on 360 it felt like a
next-gen game yeah like the amount of
detail and graphics I was blown away by
the who's the guy have you the trailer
park Trevor Trevor well I like going
there because it's like a desolate place
and I would go into their gun shop and
shoot the gun owner now we'll just run I
would just try to see how long cuz it
you know I figure do first person yeah
like I was like way out in the desert
right there's the first person do too
much you can see
you know what don't like those two like
steal a police car okay but then get
away and then put that police car in
your garage then you can go back to it
and now you have a police car
yes driving around a police car like
that's your regular car I tell you one
thing about those games I mean
soundtracks are amazing what I thought
was amazing was because I'm a nerd and I
love certain soundtracks but tangerine
dream when they did four there was a
song for it that sounded like tangerine
dream and they did five they actually
got tangerine dream to do this and that
I tell you one last thing I did in GTA
though I would shoot people like near
the mo Holland you know like that Wales
but there was like this this one patio
where you could jump over and they can't
get to you oh yeah so I would jump over
the patio and now it is always I would
camp out there mmm I start and then I
would sometimes jump out and then shoot
more cops
okay my favorite okay another favorite
thing is doing G I love that we're
talking about this I like being the
black dude what's his name I mean you
know how you could buy like the shop
where you can like yeah yeah my favorite
thing to do is to like drive over the
mountains yeah yeah I like to go
straight if I see it on the map you just
go I'm going straight like I want to
drive over the mountains I'm gonna hit
and then the car would flip over to my
favorite thing is being the white guy
and then walking but like the black
neighborhood and just walk around
because then if you just stand by like
because there's the wall street with all
the gang members you just stand there
they will just eventually start [ __ ]
with you it's the funniest [ __ ] where
you can pick up like hookers yeah of
course I used to map out like where they
were would you like honk how try to get
the nicest car I just caught myself
we had a problem it's a video game
I did one thing I love with GTA when
they said online you could [ __ ] with
your friends your friends would get on
you'd be driving around this huge city
and you could just throw [ __ ] out and
shoot them through Windows run them over
I'd be like where you at like I'd go
Chris I just mow him over with the car
that was the best part
when's the next grand theft drop and I'm
like yeah red data then after same kind
of world so yeah you're on open-world
cowboy games you go honey universe the
first mess
my favorite part was my favorite oh my
god like moment is like you get to
Mexico and like it's like right over the
like Rio Grande or whatever and like the
music comes in and the gland scape
changes to you that was beautiful but
also the random moments were great
because everywhere I was just walking
around in like the forest once it's not
doing any missions and then a bear comes
out of fall yeah no we're in the
mountains paper - tiger but there's
games within the games you can play
darts you can go watch a movie movie you
can smoke weed and there was there was
like a side mission where you had to
smoke peyote and then like you have to
chase like Bigfoot it's a secret mission
to grant the thought of light it's super
fun alright guys well let's call it
their gun was
[Music]
[Applause]